how you doing man i'm good i'm feeling
great fantastic your alphabet looks
incredible by the way thank you thank
you talk to me man you've been playing
this character for a decade now did you
ever imagine anything like that and then
and then to spin it into a series
no no of course not but i mean i uh you
know blessed with the opportunity and
it's what a wonderful way to express
uh a character and the fans are making
this happen and to be able to express it
a character in a long-form storytelling
and uh disney plus not a better place to
do it the past has caught up with me
should we be worried no no it's nothing
i'll be home for christmas i promise now
you got two series for people to watch
this mayor of kingstown what's it like
hopping back and forth between these
characters
it's a little crazy it's a bit
challenging that's great but you know
hey
i knew i had this opportunity my time in
life um to work my butt off and still
have my daughter with me and so i got
both these shows done in that time and
now i'm just happy to be able to share
them and put them out there and
and be home with my daughter and my
family so it's great yeah yeah i really
couldn't be more fortunate could not
feel more fortunate
you're a hawkeye who the hell are you
now your character kind of takes haley's
character under under his wing um was
there somebody looking back in your
career when you when you started out
that was established that helped you
along help you get started
well i mean i mean i think it just even
in the mcu you know with downey he kind
of kicked off the mcu in the way that he
did with iron man
and how he he kind of took us all under
his wing if you will to like just kind
of shepherd us in a certain way we all
knew each other and we're all friends
and just in a just in a different sort
of way yeah you can lean on somebody for
some sort of information or a hug or
something right
here's something yeah yeah
talk to me about the holidays real quick
holidays are coming up there any
traditions you look forward to or you
look forward to adding
i am the only thing that's going to be
different this year is that i'll be
sitting down and watching something that
i've
been in because i typically do that and
this is perfect to do that and i'll be
watching the show because it's very
family friendly
and my daughter's never seen anything i
do
this is the first christmas we've had
together
in years
i love you guys so typically otherwise
we'll be sledding and it's going to be a
big family affair it's amazing we love
it
but this time we get to do every
wednesday sit and watch a little bit of
hawkeye and why not it's gonna be dope